,
comment ça s'est déroulé cette
année compte tenu de la COVID.
Mais d'abord Gabrielle Proulx à
Montréal.
- Au coeur du Quartier chinois,
le Nouvel An aura encore
une fois des allures modestes.
- Un petit peu tranquille avec
ma petite famille, mais je veux
justement acheter du porc BBQ
pour manger ensemble en famille.
- On a du bon manger au Quartier
chinois. Parce que je suis
d'origine chinoise.
- On va manger. On fait
une réunion à la maison.
mme...
comment vous fêtez Noël.
- Selon le membre du Comité de
la relance inclusive du Quartier
chinois, Winston Chan, le Nouvel
An reste, malgré tout, un moment
marquant pour les communautés
chinoises à Montréal
et partout au Canada.
WINSTON CHAN, Comité relance
inclusive du Quartier chinoi
- Cette année, c'est l'année
du Tigre. Et l'année du Tigre
symbolise le courage, et aussi
la force de pouvoir surpasser
les différents obs
- Et les défis, ils ont été
nombreux au cours
des deux dernières années.
- Il y a un an à peu près,
pendant la pandémie,
il y a eu des actes de
vandalisme racistes :
entrées par infrac
des fenêtres qui sont brisées
au centre d'achat ici.
- Les restaurateurs chinois,
souvent associés à la pandémie,,
après plusieurs fermetures.
C'est le cas d'Edward Ku, qui
dit avoir tiré son épingle du
jeu grâce aux réseaux sociaux.E,
restaurant Dobe & Andy
- C'était difficile un peu.
C'est sûr que... on a trouvé
d'autres moyens, des façons
d'adapter avec la pandémie et
tout. C'est un autre début, une
autre année, alors c'est le fun.
Mais ouirès heureux
aujourd'hui. Et on va fêter ça
ce soir après le travail aussi.
Ça va être le fun.
- Dans un autre restaurant,
les tables étaient déjà
remplies en après-midi.
- Euh, c'est pas mal
ts à vents à vents à vents à ve.
- Et à l'approche de la grande
cérémonie d'ouverture à Pékin,
Winston Chan se sent fier,
mais se questionne sur la façon
a perçue la Chine
après les Jeux.
- On sait pas comment
la communauté va être...
si on va devenir un bouc
émissaire aussi à ce niveau-là.
- Reste qu'en cette nouvelle
année lunaire, on se souhaite
de façon quasi unanime...
- La bonne santé, pas de COVID!)
- Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- Un extraordinaire spectacle
de lumière, seule parcelle
de normalité des festivités
du Nouvel An lunai
Les célébrations
traditionnelles, elles,
se déroulent sans les foules
habituelles.
Resserr
sanitaires, confinement,
restrictions sur les
déplacements : la recrudescence
des cas de COVID gâche les fêtes
du Nouvel An lunaire en Chine
pour une troisième année.
Le gouvernement chinois prévoit
un 1,2 milliard de voyages
pendant cette période fériée.
On est loin des trois milliards
observés en 2019.
De nombreuses familles
chinoises ne peuvent retourner
festoyer dans leur région
natale.
C'est la première fois que cette
femme n'ira pas voir sa famille.
Celle-ci s'ennuie de sa famille,
mais elle n'oserait pas
voyager en ce moment.
Dans la bulle olympique,
décorations et activités
du Nouvel An. Des célébratio
particulières pour les bénévoles
chinois, isolés comme
les athlètes et journalistes.
"Ça sera plus animé que dans
ma famille", se réjouit-il.
Celle-ci se console en se disant
qu'elle est entourée d'amis
et de gens venus de partout
découvrir son pays.
Elle est d'ailleurs venue
partager l'esprit de la fête
à l'atelier de calligraphie
du centre des médias. Les gens
y tracent l'idéogramme
qui signifie le bonheur.
Les visiteurs peuvent
s'initier aux traditions
du Nouvel an lunaire.
On doit ensuite accrocher
ce bout de papier rouge soit
à une porte soit à une fenêtre
afin d'inviter la bonne fortune
et la chance au cours
de l'année qui commence.
Dans les villages olympiques,
festin et autres activités
pour les athlètes. Même dans
la bulle, ils ont, ils ont, ilst
l'esprit à la fête et tentent
d'exprimer quelques voeux
en mandarin.
(propos en mandarin)
L'année du Tigre commence,
symbole de force et de joie,
présage, selon certains,
d'une meilleure année.
Pour plusieurs athlètes,
les festivités vont continuer
médaille au cou.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Pék